il existe deux types de tirs le premier
et le suit est celui que l'on fait avec
précision mais sans âme dans ce cas
l'archet bien qu'il possède une grande
maîtrise de la technique s'est
exclusivement concentré sur la cible et
n'a donc pas évolué il a machinalement
répété un geste il n'a pas réussi à
grandir et l'abandonnera un jour la voie
de l'archer parce qu'il trouvera que
tout est devenu routine
les TEDx ont grandement contribué à mon
changement intérieur à la prise de
conscience de mes différents mois et à
leur dépouillement ce Ted est pour moi
un exercice particulier car ma vie de
militaire est à des millénaires de ce
que je suis maintenant c'est comme si je
n'arrivais plus à reconnecter avec ces
différents mois d'avant comme s'il
faisait partie d'un autre espace-temps
et je vous raconte une partie de mon
histoire en ayant à l'esprit le devoir
de réserve et pendant ce Ted pas
d'études scientifique avec échantillon
représentatif de la population au
programme mais des expériences celles de
la vie et de l'observation et des
ressentis
j'ai longtemps été persuadé que je serai
heureuse en ayant un travail bien sûr
bien sécurisant bien payé en étant en
couple avec des enfants en ayant plein
de beaux diplômes et en ayant
l'impression de faire partie d'une élite
perdue parmi d'autres se définissant
aussi comme tel
les diplômes j'en ai fait un combat
personnel pendant des années avec ce
furieux besoin de prouver au monde
entier un je ne sais quoi au final tout
ça dénoté avec mon besoin d'aventure
d'écriture d'imprévus d'aider les gens
je n'avais pas pleinement conscience de
ce décalage ça m'arrangeait de me mentir
à moi de même trop de travail de voir la
vérité en face et bien trop risqué
car ce dépouiller nécessite d'être
honnête avec soi-même et de décider de
voir la vérité en face
avez-vous déjà ressenti comme un
emprisonnement un étouffement dans des
rôles que vous vous octroyez petit
retour en arrière en 2009 à 24 ans je
m'engage à l'armée avec pour conviction
de servir mon pays et de vivre
l'aventure après deux ans d'école je
suis chef de section et je commande
entre 30 et 50 femmes et hommes et
j'enchaîne les missions de terrain en
France et à l'étranger à ce moment de ma
vie j'ai cette obsession d'être parfaite
sur tous les plans et de suivre ce que
bon nombre me répète ne pas montrer mes
émotions tu es chef tu dois être forte
me dit-on
après trois ans je suis sur un poste
plus politique et plus administratif
j'enchaîne toujours l'émission à
l'étranger toujours ce besoin d'aventure
d'être dans le mouvement je commence à
m'interroger sur le sens de tout ce
bazar mais je ne vais pas plus loin je
reste en surface l'autonomie dont je
bénéficie sur ce poste et le salaire qui
tombe tous les 25 du mois le comédienne
parfaitement
le poste suivant en revanche me fait
sentir un mal-être profond j'étouffe
littéralement ce que je fais n'a aucun
sens à mes yeux j'ai l'impression d'être
un automate qui exécute sans réfléchir
mais trop boulot dodo je continue à
m'interroger mais cette fois-ci sur le
sens global de la vie
un samedi après-midi
j'aperçois au loin se garer sur le
bas-côté de la route une voiture et lui
sur le siège à l'arrière je connais je
reconnais aussitôt l'une de mes
anciennes chefs de groupe du régiment
elle aussi me reconnaît aussitôt et dans
sa tête je suis toujours salieutenant
j'ai appris bien plus tard le surnom
qu'elle m'avait donné le Führer
à cet instant on s'extasie de cette
rencontre incroyable elle me raconte sa
nouvelle vie de nos bades fini l'armée
elle voyage elle rénove une maison elle
souhaite avoir son propre restaurant et
moi je suis estomaqué de voir autant de
bonheur en une seule fois
et à cette époque je suis en poste à
Balard lieu où tous les chefs d'armée
sont réunis et moi je suis estomaqué de
voir autant de bonheur en une seule fois
qu'avais-je fait de ma vie comment
mettais-je débrouillés pour en arriver
là suis-je en train de vivre de manière
anesthésiée qu'est-ce que je fuis ou
plutôt qui je fuis
environ deux ans après s'être rencontre
c'est mon mental mon corps et mon cœur
qui s'écroule et je m'autorise à
abandonner abandonner un système dans
lequel je meurs de l'intérieur des
croyances des schémas des idées toutes
faites des rôles et je décide de prendre
mes responsabilités et d'amorcer une
profonde réflexion sur moi un travail de
fond c'est le premier dépouillement
celui des uniformes la militaire de
terrain la militaire de bureau la
working woman la fitness girl la
guerrière et bien d'autres
une des expériences qui peut ouvrir
notre regard sur nos mois serait de se
questionner sur les différents uniformes
qu'on peut endosser en une journée quels
uniformes gens d'os avec qui dans quel
circonstances quand
avec qui ai-je l'impression d'être
dépouillé de mes uniformes d'être dans
ma vérité d'être moi-même
avez-vous déjà ressenti de la gêne
tellement vos placards des bords
d'affaires de toutes sortes tellement
vous avez accumulé d'objets je suis en
pleine reconversion dans les domaines de
la sophrologie et de l'hypnose je vis
dans mon appartement du 13e
arrondissement de Paris réservé aux
militaires et je m'apprête à quitter
l'armée où j'ai un poste assuré jusqu'à
la fin de ma carrière et où je suis bien
payée et je suis en couple avec un homme
qui vit à l'autre bout de la France
même si je connais des ascenseurs
émotionnels que l'on peut rencontrer
lors d'un changement de vie je
m'épanouis dans mes nouveaux
apprentissages et dans les prémices de
ce que me réserve le facteur inconnu
un après-midi je découvre que l'homme
avec qui je suis en couple est en fait
mariée en couple avec une autre personne
depuis 9 ans et à plusieurs autres
relations à ce moment c'est tout mon
monde qui s'écroule nos projets
notamment celui d'emménager ensemble
je me retrouve à devoir quitter mon
appartement et à faire des recherches de
logement et à 36 ans c'est dans une
colocatesse que je vais atterrir
je vais vivre dans un endroit où tout
est pensé pour arriver avec deux valises
maximum
seulement j'ai déjà plusieurs missions
et voyagent à l'étranger qui m'ont fait
accumuler beaucoup d'objets donc pendant
les deux mois qui me restent avant mon
emménagement je vends je trie je recycle
je donne je vois ma vie défiler à
travers tous ces objets qui sont la
matérialisation de moments de personnes
de souvenirs marquants
c'est comme
un début de tristesse qu'on ressent une
angoisse et ensuite une sorte de
libération qu'on ressent c'est plus
qu'un dévoilement matériel une mise à
une matérielle c'est un dévoilement de
notre vulnérabilité
et après avoir ressenti comme une
libération de mémoire une perte de mes
identités j'ai ressenti cette sorte de
libération cette sorte de légèreté qui
m'ont fait comprendre
que je libérais de la place pour
accueillir tout le positif qui
m'attendait
alors j'ai acheté encore du matériel et
je suis ok avec ça je ne suis pas
parfaite mais j'ai eu une prise de
conscience je me suis rassurée du mieux
que je pouvais toutes ces années à
travers tous ces objets qui m'ont fait
croire qu'ils participaient à la
construction de mémoire
c'est le deuxième dépouillement celui
des pactes
une des expériences qui peut nous
interroger sur notre relation au
matériel serait de nous questionner sur
ces possessions qui nous compliquent la
vie de celle qui nous facilitent la vie
alors l'idée n'est pas de vivre comme
les moines on vit dans un monde matériel
et on ne peut pas l'ignorer mais l'idée
ce serait de faire la part entre ces
possessions qui nous facilitent la vie
qui nous fluidifie la vie de celles qui
nous compliquent qui nous ralentissent
qui nous font sentir qu'il y a un trop
inutile
avez-vous déjà tenté de passer une
journée sans rien planifier sans rien
organiser
à l'armée il y a ce qu'on appelle le
cahier d'ordre un cahier où on note le
programme de la journée du lendemain
heure par heure avec la tenue précisée
pour chaque activité c'est un document
officiel signé par les chefs ma vie
c'était ça un cahier d'ordre que je me
donnais un moi-même à ce moment je vis
au rythme de l'encre déposé dans mon
agenda je programme tout j'anticipe tout
au millimètre près pas de place à
l'imprévu ni à la déception
lors d'une mission en Afrique je
partageais ma chambre avec des
journalistes qui réalisaient un
reportage sur l'armée française et nous
avions chacun notre clé est venu le
moment salutaire de prendre une douche
et les journalistes travaillaient dans
la chambre ni une ni deux je suis sortie
avec le strict nécessaire pour ne pas
m'encombrer mais c'était sans compter
sur le fait que je me retrouve devant la
porte de la chambre verrouillée et là
c'est le drame mes clés étaient à
l'intérieur j'ai à peine le temps de me
retourner que je retourne je me retrouve
devant l'adjudant chef qui fait 2 mètres
de haut et moi avec ma petite serviette
qui me sort c'est vous la capitaine avec
qui je fais la mission le lendemain ah
oui oui c'est moi comment vous dire qu'à
cet instant je me suis sentie très seule
parce que déjà j'étais à poil au sens
propre et figuré et deuxièmement j'avais
prévu j'avais planifié de me présenter à
lui le soir même tenu militaire carré
salut réglementaire de rigueur
des missions à l'étranger
des voyages organisés une carte du monde
parsemée d'épingles comme pour
comptabiliser une performance vide de
sens et dans l'optique de continuer mon
cheminement intérieur je suis partie en
stop au hasard sur les routes de France
pendant 11 jours je souhaite
expérimenter l'imprévu écouter
l'histoire des personnes rencontrées
questionner l'état d'hypnose comment les
personnes rencontrées au hasard peuvent
me permettre d'évoluer
c'est une véritable immersion dans la
carte du monde des personnes rencontrées
mais aussi dans la mienne
j'ai prolongé cette expérience en
partant cette fois-ci en stop sans
argent sans eau sans nourriture sans
matériel dépouiller de toutes ces choses
auxquelles on peut s'identifier
on m'a dit mais c'est génial d'où cette
challenge que tu te lances mais comment
expliquer et faire comprendre avec des
mots qui ne sont même plus suffisants
que ce n'est pas des challenges que je
veux me lancer mais plus subtil que ça
parce que la connaissance n'est pas le
tout savoir parce qu'au-delà de ce
savoir apprendre à douter et à se mettre
en posture d'apprenti de la vie permet
de dissoudre certains schémas certaines
croyances certains biais cognitifs qui
nous sclérose et qu'expérimenter et
incarné son nécessaire pour apprendre à
se connaître au-delà de ces mois
cahier d'ordre incertitude aucun des
deux n'est pas diabolisé mais de temps
en temps la chose de notre main le fil
conducteur de la vie pour se laisser
porter par le fil de la vie le
déséquilibre est normal il est même
rassurant et enseignant
c'est le troisième des poumons celui des
ordres qu'on s'impose
une expérience que vous pouvez tenter et
de vous programmer dans votre agenda une
heure une demi-journée une journée où
vous ne prévoyez rien et d'observer à ce
moment vos ressentis physiques mentaux
et émotionnel
et de vous poser la question suivante de
quoi ai-je besoin ici et maintenant
avez-vous tenté d'être pleinement à
l'écoute de l'autre lors d'une
conversation par pleinement
j'entends le regarder dans les yeux et
ne pas regarder votre téléphone ne pas
vous perdre dans la pré qu'est-ce que je
vais manger ce soir j'ai encore les
courses à faire
aujourd'hui on en vient à payer pour
quelque chose de gratuit tel que le
silence alors que la vie en elle-même
est une expérimentation une hypnose
universelle gratuite
il y a quelques mois j'ai réalisé un
séjour dans le silence sans téléphone
sans écran ni parole pendant 6 jours
dans un monde où il devient
insupportable d'attendre un métro plus
de 5 minutes sans se furieux besoin de
regarder son téléphone dans un monde où
nous avons la tête baissée et n'avons
même plus la force de l'alro de la
relever pour observer pour contempler
durant ce séjour le silence m'a amené à
m'ennuyer à observer à expérimenter
l'authenticité à m'émerveiller davantage
et encore mais aussi à me délester de
mes narratifs de mes discours
auto-entretenus et victimisant personne
ne m'aime j'ai pas de chance mais aussi
de mes schémas narratifs de mes
promesses faites à moi-même
je dois être épanouie je suis obligée de
il faut que
c'est le quatrième dépouillement celui
de la parole verbale celui de la parole
qu'on se donne des promesses qu'on se
fait à soi-même de nos narratifs de nos
discours auto-entretenus
apprendre à se taire pour être
pleinement avec l'autre la prochaine
fois qu'une personne vous ouvrira son
cœur
tentez l'expérience de vous taire tout
simplement de l'écouter et de vous
exprimer quand elle a réellement fini de
s'exprimer observer ce qu'il se passe et
ce que vous ressentez
ma vie d'avant celle de maintenant qui
suis-je qu'est-ce que je fais je dirais
plutôt qu'est-ce que j'expérimente alors
j'ai écrit un livre qui propose des
outils pour apprendre à mieux se
connaître mais aussi un roman je me
forme en ce moment sur le genre de la
romance mais j'accompagne aussi des
personnes via l'écriture via l'aventure
via le stop thérapeutique et je prends
aussi des bus au hasard et bientôt
peut-être des trains au hasard pour
expérimenter l'imprévu et voir où la vie
me mène
et j'ai peur
et c'est normal
changer le monde ça commence par notre
changement intérieur et pas besoin
d'aller jusqu'à les faire des retraites
spirituelles pour ça des retraites
silencieuses il s'agit de commencer par
prendre le temps d'apprendre à se
connaître d'identifier ses besoins et
les respecter en arrêtant de faire de sa
vie un perpétuel combat pour mieux se
fuir en s'autorisant à abandonner parce
que oui l'abandon parfois peut-être
salvateur en se délestant de ces mois
qu'on s'invente à différents moments de
la journée et parfois toute une vie
en prenant de la distance avec ces mois
on réalise qu'on est capable de bien
plus que ce qu'on croit il devient
urgent de vivre
urgent de se délester de ses mensonges
pour apprendre à mieux se connaître
plutôt que de vous demander quel métier
je souhaiterais faire je vous invite à
vous demander
quelles expériences je souhaiterais
vivre
le second tir est celui que l'on fait de
toute son âme lorsque l'intention de
l'archer se transforme pour devenir le
vol de la flèche ses doigts s'ouvrent au
bon moment et le son de sa corde fait
chanter les oiseaux et le fait de tirer
en direction de quelque chose au loin
provoque paradoxalement un retour sur
soi une rencontre avec soi-même et je
rajouterai à cela
sortez de vos cercles le monde est à vos
pieds merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]